Oh your boom how are you my friend it's
it's almost that time right and you know
I get excited hearing that music because
that this generation when we were doing
it it was like the NFL Films music for
us when they were young right no doubt
no doubt when did you first realize you
and TJ had something going this huh
you know we were together twenty nine
years as you know on TV prime time for
what nineteen and he really quick sure
not to overstate things but by eighty
seven I had met a lot of the players who
were really good you know Tommy played
fourteen years many Pro Bowls etc I had
not met Tom yet so when he came in for
his audition he was I'll tell you the
story he was the seventh of seven this
is the last guy never get or lady never
gets the job nice job but he just wowed
everybody by just being himself and
there were two things that stand out at
the very beginning one was when we went
over what we're gonna do and I did the
auditions not that I had anything to do
with choosing really Steve Anderson and
above but okay we're gonna go over this
highlight we'll look at that several
times and you know the technical blah
blah blah and then for ten or fifteen
minutes are just gonna talk about
football and he looked at me rich like a
little kid going you mean we're just
gonna talk about football
I said yet don't worry about the cameras
you and I are just having a discussion
it was like the most innocent but
relieved look I ever saw and then week
one 1987 our first week of prime time
our first we and game day then as you
remember we were watching all the games
at 1:00 and the war room as we do yeah
it's like 1:30 somebody had a big hit
right and Tom goes wow look at that hiss
I don't what hold on calmed isn't that
what you did for 14 years as a
linebacker with the Broncos and he went
well he may be but but look at that head
he was a fan
instantly of a game that he excelled
that for 14 years so the answer was
almost immediately to answer your
question yeah you had a did it hello and
I just you know remember that show
essentially I mean it just it made fans
out of the game
Chris there's just no two ways about it
because I remember growing up as I'm
sure you remember for sure as well was
Cosell doing the highlights of Monday
Night Football at halftime and I
remember I would get my brother and I
would get pissed when the Jets were not
making that montage we thought we were
disrespected that Cosell did not put
that or whatever producer didn't put it
in at the time and to me like that show
was in that vein like that prime time
was was was the natural ascension of of
that Monday night highlight segment the
evolution those Monday that highlights
will Revere because remember well you
remember you didn't see all the games
cept if you happen to get that NFL Films
show toward the end of the week right so
primetime was an hour of show me as if
it was fifty one to forty five not as
much in those days but let you say it's
a wild game why don't you go six or
seven minutes on that it was and it was
the it was the third and three in the
mud up by two minute and a half to go
you made a three yard for a four yard
run but it clinched the game we could
show that to you never saw those place
so here's the thing that as I look back
at it and it was really my professional
tool stone that's gonna be really high I
would think it tips are my favorite show
obviously and we shared it with football
fans we shared it with people in
football I would watch it whether Tom
and I were doing it or tour you and
another analysts were doing it you had
to see it it was well if Seattle and
Arizona had a wild game here you go we
I saw that so it was a great invention
Steve born Stein Pete Rozelle kind of
together right thought it up with I
guess with me in mind at the time I
don't know well I dunno but ER
that it was a it also as I found out
later rich was a gathering place for our
industry and I don't really mean the
community you know the sports casting
although sure it was but the football
industry
I remember in an owner's meeting I was
floored early like late eighties Don
Shula came up we had really enjoyed
watching your show I said because it
really helps me with teams down the line
as a wait a minute coach you know you
have game film we're not showing you
what you need to see cuz I know but
let's say we're playing the the dolphins
are playing the NFC East this year and
we haven't seen them for whatever four
years and I'll start paying attention to
the Giants of the Redskins on your show
for five weeks ahead sometimes make a
couple of notes of some things I see and
then we get within a week or two and
I'll have the guys go find and look at
those aspects of what I saw on NFL
primetime and I went if Don Shula is
watching NFL primetime to help him win
games it must be pretty good yeah you're
onto something you're on something
that's fantastic Chris Berman of ESPN
right here on the Rich Eisen show well
let's talk about the here and now you
know Chris I'm again I'm assuming you
don't have the ESPN app or other apps on
your phone I'm wondering how did you
learn about the Andrew Luck because
you're not on social media either how
did you learn about the Andrew Luck
retirement I happened to have the TV on
that night then actually and and I don't
often I'm in and out and about a lot of
places but I happened to watch a little
baseball and then turned over to see
that the Chargers play the Seahawk and
you gonna figured the first quarter or
two people that I knew would be playing
the Russel Wilson was Philip Rivers
wasn't
and then there was so
and can we compare it I mean I you know
we all the names obviously it's several
days later I mean Jim Brown Barry
Sanders two guys retired at the top of
their game you know Andrew you can throw
Koufax in there too from baseball but
anyone that thinks ill of him his heart
was in every second he was in that
building I I don't even know how people
think ill of him or his decision I I
don't get that line of thinking you know
he I mean he's just good at his
upstanding person let alone talent that
that we've had in our game the last
decade don't you agree agreed absolutely
no doubt about it no doubt about it and
also you do is you look at some of the
NFL films of his career and just see how
intense he could be on the solid one
that I bet that left out to me over the
weekend where Chuck Pagano is telling
him you are not going back in this game
this game's over
we need you down the road if you get
hurt what in the world would happen you
know that he tried to get back I mean
look it even sounds silly to try and
defend the position Chris I mean you
know there's one thing written and you
hate to already ok sum it up but yeah I
come back he and the Colts mate against
the Chiefs pretty darn good I know you
know Andrew and their goals were to win
more games like that and higher up the
ladder if you will in January and they
didn't to do it but I mean that year
between Peyton Manning and then Andrew
Luck or whatever I mean that was the
Colts were what were they when Peyton
was hurt you know and he immediately
made them good again and franchise that
that was about to not be paid attention
to nationwide for a few years really but
what he went there they were contending
for division and playoff and I mean and
that's him he's not alone only be the
first to tell you but it it's a shame
that for football that we lose
a talent and a person like that but look
he he thought about this a long time I
mean I'm not in the know there but I
this is this is real life and you know
you do want to pick up your kids at some
point and if that was going to be an
issue well then he made the only
decision that it could via con Dios
after that we've got a couple of days
now until the beginning of the season
are you are you close to making a
prediction do you have won four Super
Bowl contenders this year Chris not not
yet I probably you know I know the SWAT
you know it's still still you know I
haven't rubbed all the angles of the
crystal ball yet or the top of my er
your head which always comes in handy
right when making these predictions have
you bet been off I mean you a lot of
people around the Chiefs I personally
would love to see Andy Reid have that
chance they really pretend seconds we're
in the Super Bowl last year until
everybody noticed that the flag on D
Ford which was correct but Wow
right but for ten seconds they were
going to the Super Bowl that so I I
haven't so I I believe I leaned them you
know New England won and I've seen them
up close read last few days and I why
would it song as Bill Belichick and Tom
Brady there why would we not look at
them but I mean that's defending champ
what I what you know what's amazing let
me turn it just a bit go for it so we
look at the 12 playoff teams from last
year right maybe there's two or three do
you go I don't know but how can these
eight or nine not get back in you say it
every year and six sometimes seven
sometimes five but six or seven don't
make it like you look at it now right
rich and you go well there is and for
example in the AFC I'm am just doing
this up top my head
New England well they're going to be in
right now ok so now the Colts have
change so there's one
already but that wasn't one we were
talking about necessarily three four
years ago well we know the cheeps are in
right I mean we think we think the
Chargers are good so that's these are
holdovers yeah and Pittsburgh didn't
make it in Cleveland didn't make it so
maybe those are a couple of teams that
will change and we did it again I'm
glossing over right I mean we think the
Eagles are going to get in we think the
Saints are going to get in right we
think the Rams are going to get in these
are playoff teams we think so I think
they're going to get in the Cowboys all
right cowboy still healthy and
Pittsburgh wasn't them last year so
there are two teams but are we gonna
have six new teams in the playoffs hard
to see on August whatever day we are now
27 but in December it's like how did we
not see this coming it it's interesting
how that works
every year it it it is it was seven last
year and now you got the Cowboys
obviously you were front and center
talking every single day when Emmet was
holding now this this does look like it
could be Emmett 2.0 with Zeke although
you know I think Jerry does realize that
maybe this team needs Zeke more than
that team needed Emmett and he's going
to get something done I wonder what you
think Chris you would think so I mean
Jerry look Jerry learns like everyone
else Jerry is very smart it's not like
okay I'll never do that again well these
are different circumstances in his eyes
and I'm not even close to being aware of
what other than the dollar sign and the
length I mean there's probably other
things that's preventing this from being
done and you make a good point is he
more it's hard to say anyone was more
important than then Emmett was to them
because that was always an asterisk
right I don't think they want any
preseason games and if you didn't win
any preseason games at least back then
when they were playing more you
going to the playoffs that was like a
2/3 non-playoff result the bureau and
for you wouldn't think so right well
they didn't have em it I don't think
they want appreciate again and then
there oh no that's the oh and to start
with yes the asterisk was they didn't
have M it and now they did right so is
he more important well he's equally
important and the way that team is built
with that line that you know when they
get away from just handing him the ball
I go back to his rookie year
remember the Packer playoff game all of
a sudden they were throwing and
dipsy-doodle and they were behind like
21 to 3 before they knew what was
happening and there's the biggest
example of if you don't run a horse but
behind a really good offensive line
which can wear down everybody what do
you what do you have him for so I would
like to think now who knows what kind of
shape he's in if he gets signed Thursday
before the opener rich but I got to
think that he's not sitting like Le'Veon
Bell I I don't I don't think so it
sounds like you don't think so either
no I mean it Le'Veon didn't have a
contract last year Zeke does I mean he
would be he would both did obviously
lose money I just find it hard to
believe that Jerry Jones wouldn't get
something done and just call up the few
extra million that he might be trying to
hold back because of whatever Zeke did
off the field and used that to his
advantage in some sort of negotiation I
think he's just gonna swallow and just
make sure that this kid is in in truck I
think they can win the Super Bowl this
year Chris I really do they're that good
defensively I do and I you know dak dak
made it to the second round last year so
it's entirely possible that they that
they can do it this year but Zeke's got
to play all 16 in my mind yeah he does
their defense is coming as you know yeah
and you're right dak now has been in
there
you would think just any team losing
Super Bowl always has a slip that
doesn't mean that the Rams are going to
slip some but maybe they're not as
formidable maybe the Saints look I mean
who knows yeah we they got job
etc but I mean at some point does that
have a negative effect not the same as
Atlanta who you know did 28 to 3 I mean
they haven't been late in the playoffs
they did make it once but you deep these
things that don't go your way even if
they should have in New Orleans this
case by the way there was more game to
play they weren't ahead then
so if the best two teams Rams Saints we
think are going back a little the NFC
seems to be the one where there's more
room at the number one on the number two
teams whoever we think we are wearing
wears in the the AFC I mean yes you
could make a case that New England and
Kansas City or not one two or two one
but it's harder to see several Cerner to
see them falling back in the same way
that the Rams and Saints by a couple of
wins that that's that's kind of how I
should on August 27th but an unofficial
swami just through the binoculars last
one for you Chris before I let you go
I'm in town because the NFL 100 campaign
is launching tonight in earnest you are
part of the blue-ribbon panel of experts
that voted on the all-time team that's
going to be announced later on this fall
what was your criteria do you did you
have any or just you saw somebody you
just knew that that person was gonna
make your team well how did you how did
you go about that well that's a good
question because first of all I was kind
of blown away why I prefaced a lot of my
statements when we had our meetings and
conference calls that you know here's
Bill Belichick and Don Shula and I can
go on Gil Brandt I mean I could mention
all the names and then Here I am it's
like what am I doing here
but that being said to me my criteria
it's kind of like voting rich for an MVP
there is no absolute rule if you're
voting for player or the in other words
what I'm trying to say is MVP it's not
an exact science or did you win the
batting title
let's baseball courses how many home
runs did you have set hurt or how many
yards rushing did you have but was your
team seven and nine so therefore am I
still voting for this guy is MVP even
though his team is to play so by saying
that I'm I'm a history guy now that
doesn't mean I bent over backwards for
it but I a couple of the founders like
the Red Grange even Jim Thorpe I gave
them more weight and I because I don't
think we're having this meeting or this
unveiling of the team or etcetera if
those guys didn't do what they did so
was Jim Thorpe and his limited playing
days as good as Emmitt Smith I mean I
know but in a few cases a few I I
weighed history not that many but a few
I thought that was important because I
didn't think everybody would do it that
way I will say this and if you do it
yourself I may not you could I don't
want to bore everybody with the correct
you know we we all voted for a certain
number it nobody's ranked we should say
it but this team comes out which I don't
know who's on it you know that they
would have to get rid of me if I like
and I don't know so if we voted for I
think it was maybe 18 quarterbacks first
time through all right but in the end
what I think it was 10 you're not ranked
but just 10 it doesn't matter well in
every position and you can do it
yourself rich when you're off air and
maybe you have I was very quickly
realized that about two-thirds or
three-fourths so let's say seven or
eight of the 10 quarterbacks were yeah
you can't they're on and that left like
seven guys for two spots in in that
particular area and I forget if we were
ten or twelve
runningbacks at this time it but it was
the same thing that about 2/3 to 3/4
were like really when we discussed why
perceivers I don't think we discussed
Jerry Rice yes why why would you there
it is you see what I'm saying they're
the seven for the last three spots were
agonizing it was fun in retrospect but I
had to play the culture caught a few
with yeah you know I know so I wait a
little bit of history when I could and
and certainly looked at stats and and
longevity and other things but there was
no everyone's criteria was I think their
own that yours might be a little
different than mine were you a voter on
it you know and I was honored to do it
we also did the coaches and again I
think what do we pick ten cultures yes
and two-thirds of them are there on with
reports and now you've got seven / -
that was really fascinating and a fun
way to look back at the greats
who's Buster and Kenton and a few I
might add that aren't in there that I I
may have put on although I did just a
few most are in there but not all so and
I don't know how everyone else felt if
they're not in the Hall of Fame well
then who am i to consider that may have
been a criteria it is but not a
believably defining one for me you know
like I that that that sort of a boy was
fun I gotta tell you but I've we spent a
lot of time over it Chris you're the
best thanks for the call I look forward
to the next time whether we run into
each other I have you on once again
all right listen ESPN is 40 years old
September 7th you were part of it too
I'll buy a couple of pieces of cake okay
I love a crest save one for me I
appreciate that it's an honor for you
even consider me worthy of a slice of
that cake well you deserved it you guys
were fun you and Stewart great thanks
to keep up the hard work my man you you
work too hard every time I see it thanks
to the call Chris appreciate it see ya
you got it it's wrong you got it for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app